I'm so excited just because a long time
I didn't see you
with me and DB is
and now I need my ass to complete the
team
I'm about to step into my whole new life
now Morocco is my home
naturally I have concerns
you know with my son Julian nagging me
constantly he plants all those seeds in
me
there's a part of me that's very
insecure and I want Osama to say Debbie
it's going to be okay no matter what I
need that
I want to give Osama the lead as far as
when we're going to go get married
but I'd like to get married in about a
month
[Music]
it's Osama come on
he looks handsome
hey Osama
or someone
oh so much
it seems like a dream doesn't it
the half was missing is getting
connected much yes yes
our Strange connection
so it's about beautiful yes
You're My Strange beautiful
too
[Laughter]
I love you just for beginning yourself
can you close your eyes
can you open them
oh thank you
thank you
[Laughter]
I love that
I feel like I'm in a dream like trance
almost like I can't stop myself from
staring at him and coming to him like a
magnet it's like a force that words
can't describe
[Music]
thank you